So if we put BRCA1 in the context of how we actually get a breast tumor. The
epidemiological data shows that if you have a
normal BRCA1, there's about a 12% risk of having
breast cancer. Whereas if you have this 5382
insertion of cytosine in the BRCA1 coating region, you
end up with about a 60% risk of
breast cancer. Now what's actually happening here, BRCA1 when
there's a fully functional protein is able to
repair DNA damage, right we said its normal function
is actually maintain genetic stability in a cell
and it helps to fix certain kinds of mutations.
This insertion of a cytosine causes a frameshift
which does change a lot if amino acids but
it also probably is going to end up. With a
stop codon earlier than expected which would truncate or
shorten the protein and its overall function is
going to be disrupted. Because it can't carry out
its function of fixing these mutations inside the cell.
Those mutations can persist, cause other problems, and eventually
turn into a tumor. So now our risk is elevated to about 60%. So how does a
BRCA1 protein normally repair mutations that it finds in.
Breast tissue cells. Well you remember from lesson six,
we learned that there are induced mutations that
can come from many places including X-ray energy. It
can actually nick the DNA backward and literally cut
a DNA strand in half like this. Remember, this
is bad news bears. This is like separating
a chromosome. This is not good, a cell needs
to fix this quickly. BRCA1 is a critical protein
that's able to get these two broken strands of
DNA back together again. Of course it has the help of
a lot of other proteins as well. But as long as
BRCA1 is functioning efficiently with all the other proteins. Then we
can actually fix this mutation and get our DNA strand glued
back together. So although there were other back up repair mechanisms,
without a fully functioning BRCA1 the DNA has a higher chance
of going unrepaired and eventually enough mutations occur, it could cause
the cells to grow out of control and form a tumor,
thus, your risk for breast cancer with the BRCA1
mutation. Is much higher. So based on this function
for BRCA1, what would you expect, this 5382 insertion
of cytosine, the frameshift mutation to be? Dominant? Or recessive?